it is Friday and you know what that
means notable quotables it's kind of
insulting Canadians were polite we're
reasonable but we also will not be
pushed around there's a special place in
the hell for any foreign leader that
engages in bad faith diplomacy with
President Donald J Trump
I think it's going to be the biggest
photo off of the 21st century it's gonna
go viral on social media I'm John I was
a weirdo we have developed a very
special fog butcher working with him is
like trying and feverish he is a killer
negotiate with Donald Trump it pays to
have a nuclear bomb in your pocket I
think he may be going the extra mile to
make sure that his report is as
bulletproof as it can be you can attack
me all you want I'm used to it I enjoy
it however when it comes to attacking
staff that's when you've gone too far
not today or tomorrow or at any point
ever going to comment on Rudy Giuliani's
love life I will say makes me feel very
uncomfortable
[Applause]
one week hard to believe